Our last handler is NewPost handler. This actually should look fairly familiar to you.
This kind of has the general kind of form submission error handling process
we've been using before.
If you just do a get on that page /newpost, we return the newpost.html.
If you post to it, we try to verify the forms.
The first thing to do is we get the two parameters out of the request--subject and content.
Those are the name of the form fields.
If we don't have a subject and content, we will do this clause first.
We create an error message "subject and content please,"
and we render the form again with the user's entered subject, content, and error.
Newpost.html expects these parameters.
If they did enter a good subject and content we create a new post.
I set my parent. Again, you don't have to set a parent.
It might make future organization easier. I was learning data store myself.
I set the subject equal to subject that the user entered
and I set the content to be the content that the user entered.
Remember the two date parameters created and last modified would be set automatically.
We call p.put to store this element in the database.
Then I redirect the user to /blog/ the ID of the element,
and this is how you get an object's ID and datastore.
Let's see this in action in the browser one more time now that we know what all the pieces are.
Here we are in the new post again. Let's submit this form without a subject and body.
You can see that we have the error message "subject and content please."
We'll enter a subject and a little body, and when we click submit,
we get redirected to /blog/4, which is the ID of this post.
You can see our subject and our body, and if we go back to our blog's front page,
you can see all of our entries. That's the homework.